k-nearest neighbor is instance-based or lazy
learning. That means that you get all the answers
in one big splash. If something changes in your
data then you have to rerun the algorithm from
scratch. This might make it difficult to scale
these models because you're working with much
more data at any one time. Sometimes you don't
want instance-based machine learning algorithms.
Instead, you'll want to see a continuous numerical
relationship between different parts of your data.
For that, you might use something
like regression analysis.
Regression analysis looks at the relationship
between predictors and your outcome. Sometimes
you'll hear predictors called input variables,
independent variables, or even regressors.
Linear regression is one of the most common
types of machine learning algorithms.
With linear regression, you'll want to create a
straight line that shows the relationship between
your predictor and the outcome. You'll want
to see all the different data points closely
gathered around the straight line. Then you
can make the best prediction of your outcome.
Let's think about how this might work.
Imagine you're an owner of an ice cream shop.
Over the last year, you've collected 20 days
of sales data. Then you went out and purchased
the weather data for those days. So, with this
training data, you create a simple x and y-axis
diagram as a scatter plot. This is when you plot
your data along different parts of your diagram.
Along the y-axis, you list the daily sales. And
along the x-axis, you put a temperature scale.
Let's say it starts at 60 degrees and ends at 110
degrees so you plot all of your different data
points on your diagram. Then you'll try to create
a line of best fit. To do this, you create a line
that splits your data. This is usually called the
hyperplane. Sometimes you'll also hear this called
the trend line. So, you can see from our scatter
plot diagram that there's a very clear trend line.
The more the temperature goes up, the greater your
ice cream sales. You can also see that there's a
few times that you have data points that are well
outside the trend line. This could be because
there was a festival or maybe just a lot of people
wanted ice cream on a cold day. If you have a lot
of data points that are far away from the trend
line, then it will be much more difficult for you
to predict your ice cream sales. As it stands,
there aren't many outliers so you can use your
linear regression to predict your sales.
Let's look at a point in this diagram. Let's
say that all this week, the weather forecast
says it will be around 95 degrees. Now we can
look at our hyperplane or trend line and try to
find the corresponding ice cream sales. You'll
see that you can expect to sell around $3,000.
As you can imagine, not just ice cream shop owners
are interested in using machine learning linear
regression. In fact, if you have more data, it's
usually easier to make an accurate trend line.
One interesting about linear regression is
that there are some debate about whether
it's actually machine learning. There's some
truth to it because if you think about it,
the machine is not actually learning anything
new about the data. It's just using the data
to create a standard statistical model. It's
less about learning and more about predicting.
Either way, regression is a very popular way to
try and predict future behavior. The key is to
find the right predictors and look for some
type of linear connection with the outcome.